[موسيقى]
انا شخص مختص بالفيزياء
وحقيقه انا مو بس يعني مختص فيها انا
احبها واستمتع بها
وكوني انا مختص في الفيزياء وبحب الفيزياء
فبحب دائما ابدا كلامي بتجربه
انا اليوم في عندي هذه الورقه
متى اي ورقه طبيعيه من اي دفتر من اي مكان
فيكم تجيبوها انا هذه الورقه اذا جيت نفخت
من تحت شو بصير فيها
بتطلع لفوق صح معقول مثلا نضل في مكانها
لا طبعا
بطلع لفوق
طيب اذا جيت انا ونفخته من فوق
شو ممكن يصير فيها
معقول مثلا تطلع لفوق
طبيعي
طلعت لفوق
نرجع نعيد
طيب هذا الشيء ليش بصير بصير ببساطه لانه
الهواء هو عباره عن جسيمات صغيره من
الهواء وتظهر شو هو
انا بمجرد ما ازيد سرعه الهواء فوق الورقه
بتحم جزيئات الهواء فوق الورقه بخلي ضغطه
خفيف جدا بصير عدد الجزيئات قليله جدا
فبتصير الضغط خفيف جدا هنا بالمقابل تحت
بصير الضغط اعلى فبيطلع لفوق
هذا المبدا البسيط جدا عملوا منه اختراع
كلياتنا نشتغل عليه اليوم شو هو
الطائره
الطائره بحل الاطنان الكبيره جدا شلون
بتكون تبقى معلقه في الهواء
ببساطه على حسب هذا المبدا بجيبوا
شو اسمه هذا
الجناح شكرا الجناح بيحطوه بشكل من فوق
يكون سرعه الهواء عالي اسرع من تحت فكل ما
زاد سرعه الهواء شو بصير فيه بيقل الضغط
من فوق الضغط تحت بصير اعلى فيبقيها معلقه
الهواء فقط بمجرد ما يزيد سرعته بخفض ضغط
بطالع كل الاطمانه الكبيره جدا من الحديد
السؤال
وقت انتو اكتشفتوا معي الان هذه المعلومه
البسيطه الكبيره
هل عقلكم استمتع هل حسيت انه اه انا ترى
اليوم تعلمت شيء جديد شفت نوو والله حلو
من هالورقه اوكي شي جميل بتلاقي انه مخك
استمتع من دون اي اراده منك السؤال
هذه المتعه من اين اتت
حدا علمنا اياها
هل هي اختيار منك الجواب لا
الجواب هو انها الفطره
هي فطره موجوده في في في جواتك في احشائك
منذ ان ولدت تستمتعي بحب الاكتشاف انشات
ما بيت هو موجود أنت ما بدك اياه لطالما
انت تتعلم شيء جديد وتحب يعني تكتشف شيء
جديد تحبه
بتحب تستمتع فيه هذا شيء موجود هذا الشيء
موجود عن فئتين من الناس كنت بدي اقول
اول شخص او اول فئه من الناس
هم العلماء
العلماء ناس بيحبوا يكتشفوا يشيلوا
ويجربوا ويعملوا ويطالعوا ويكتبوا معادلات
ويخترعوا ويسووا الى اخره هذا هو التطور
اللي بيعمله
هذا الشيء نحن نعرفه ولكن في فئات ثانيه
كثير واضحه فيها هذه الصفه مين هي
الاطفال
الاطفال هم علماء صغار
ولكن هم علماء
بيحب يكتشف كثير السؤال بده يستنتج هاي
وبده يشيل هاي وبده يحط هاي
فاللي بصير انه بمجرد هذه الفطره موجوده
بتلاقي انه في قدامك مشروع عالم عم بشتغل
قدامك في كثير منا ما له حاسس عليه انه هو
فعلا بهذه الفطره هو مشروع عالم
وهنا في عندي سؤال برفع اليد بصراحه يعني
انا ما راح ازعل كم واحد بيكره الفيزياء
صراحه راحه طب انا زعلت
طيب
منطقي هذا الكلام لو ما كان حدا رفع ايده
كنت استغربت
ليش بتكره الفيزياء
راح اجاوبكم بعد هذه التجربه
في عنا
في عنا كرتونه قويه وفي عنا ورقه اي ورقه
بتصير اي ورقه حتى لو جريده تمام جيت انا
قبل ما احط الورقه اذا بحطها بهذا الشكل
الكرتونه اذا ضربتها بقوه شو بصير فيها
بتطير صح طبيعي
لكن لو وجبت ورقه خفيفه جدا
تمام حطيتها بهذا الشكل
وجيت
شوف شو عم بعمل لاحظوا اكتشفوا شو عم بعمل
تمام
نحطه هيك
واحد
اثنين ثلاثه
انكسرت
صفقولي
طبعا بتشوفوها بالاعاده البطيئه انكسرت
ليش مع انه شوفوا اذا نفس الورقه جبتها
وحطيتها هيك حطيتها بهذا الشكل
راح تطير
بيكون السؤال بشو شو اللي صار اللي صار
ببساطه انه في مساحه كبيره في تحت فورا
صافي فراغ فجائي تحت الخشب
تحت الخشب صار في فراغ فجائي فالضغط فيه
خفيف جدا فالضغط الجوي هجم عليه من فوق
فضغطوا من الاعلى
طبقت الجو هو اللي خلاه مثبت في العدد
الطاوله يعني باختصار هذا الضغط الجوي
كله اخذنا الضغط الجوي بس كم واحد اخذه
بهذا الشكل
السؤال هنا
انه ما في حدا يا جماعه بيكره اللي انتم
هلا شفتوه مستحيل وخاصه اذا عرفت وين
يستخدم وشو الاختراعات اللي طالع منها واو
شي كثير حلو لكن هو ما بيكره الفيزياء هو
بيكره الطريقه اللي وصلته الفيزا لعنده
ومش بس الفيزياء الكيمياء والعلوم وكل
العلوم الثانيه
فالنقطه مهمه جدا جدا انه وقت الشخص يعلم
يمتع المتلقي هذه نقطه في غايه الاهميه
في عالم اسمه ريتشارد فاينمن هو عالم
فيزياء ولقب باذكى رجل في العالم في السنه
من السنوات وحاصل على شو اسمه هذا
جائزه نوبل في سنه من السنوات
قال انت كيف صرت هذا الشخص العبقري لانه
هو شخص فعلا وقت بيشرح بيستمتع وهو بيشرح
قال له انت كيف صرت بهذا بهذه المتعه بهذه
الابداع
قال له انا ابي شخص تاجر طبيعي تاجر البسه
متوسط الدخل شخص طبيعي جدا ولكن كان يعمل
معي التالي هذا الكلام من كتاب متعه
اكتشاف الاشياء هذا اسمه الكتاب
قال كان ابي يعمل معي التالي لطالع مني
هذه او هذا هذه الصفه او اصير عالم اسمعوا
يا جماعه هذا الكلام المدرسين للاولياء
الامور اول شغله انا علمني اياها التساؤل
كيف اتساءل اكثر مو اتساءل يعني
تساؤل من السؤال تمام يكون في عندي سؤال
كثير كيف قال انا كل اسبوع كان ابي يمسكني
بايدي ويمشي معي الى الغابه
كتير من الاشياء اقعد مساله هاي ليش بطير
هيك هذا ليش لونه هيك هذا طويل هذا تخين
هذا واسع هذا يتحرك هذا صغير اسئله كثيره
ويحاولوا انهن يجاوبوا عليه بغض النظر اذا
لقوا ولا لا هو ما عم يعلمه يجاوب على
السؤال لا لا وبعلمه كيف يتساءل لدرجه انه
يعرف يسال السؤال الصح
لانه من يفقد القدره على السؤال يفقد
القدره عن التغيير
قولا واحدا هاي نقطه النقطه الثانيه
اللي علمه اياها ابوه للابن لهذا العالم
الخيال
شخص يتخيل شخص
ويعطيه القصه البسيطه ويفتح له اياها
ويقعد يقرا له ولد صغير يقعد يقرا له يقول
له هلا في مثلا فيل
يتحرك من كذا كذا بسكر الكتاب ويحط على
جنب ويقول دعنا نتخيل ماذا يعني هذا
ويجيبوا مثلا الان انتم موجودين على هذا
المسرح تخيلوا انه موجود فيل قديش ممكن
يكون طوله بالنسبه لالي اذا مشي شلون عم
بيطلع الصوت وين ممكن يوقف كان يعلمه هذا
الخيال اللي انتم بتحاولوا تعملوه يربط
لها في الواقع هذه النقطه اساسيه جدا في
انه فعلا يطلع منه عالم الشغله الثالثه
كان يعلمه عندما
تتعلم استمتع
استمتع قال له مثلا كان عم يحكيوا عن قضيه
العطاله او القصور الذاتيه او لنرشا او
اللي هو تمام
مبدا روح خذ خذ الطابه وروح على شاحنه
وخلي الشاحنه تمشي راح تلاقي انه
رجعت لورا الشاحنه مشت الطابه راح وقف
التوراه الطابه راح تمشي لقدام وبعدين بلش
نقاش يستمتع بما يتعلم هذه النقاط ثلاثه
طالعت منه من متعه اكتشاف الاشياء في
التعليم طلعت منه
النقطه اللي بعدها طبعا في دكتور فيزيائي
بيدرس في جامعه ام اي تي اسمه
يقول يا جماعه هذه الكلمه خطيره يقول مجرم
من يفصل المتعه عن التعلم
انت قضيت على علم كامل اذا ما استمتع في
المتلقي يعني اي شخص سمعتوه ان هو بيكره
ماده عرف انه في مشكله في التلقي هو مش
ذنبه
متعه اكتشاف الاشياء فتره فبمجرد ما هو
تعلم راح ينبسط فيها راح يحبها فاذا ما
كانت موجوده هذه المطعم موجوده عنده ففي
شيء غلط راح يصير
في واحد الفكره الاخرى في واحد سال انه طب
حتى بالتدريس يعني حتى بالدراسه عفوا لازم
استمتع بالشيء اللي انا بدي اياه
كان في عالم اسمه نيكولا تسلا مايكل
فاراداي عفوا مايكل فاراداي وهو عم بيكتشف
ومستمتع بالشيء اللي هو بده اياه اكتشف
التحريض الكهرومغناطيسي او الكهراطيسه
وانبسط فيه والى اخره في واحد دجى من
الناس اللي بيحبوا
الماده فقط لا عيب انه واحد يحب الماده
ولكن كل شيء تربط ربط مباشر غلط له
استراتيجيه بغض النظر ساله سؤال الو ما
فائده هذا الاكتشاف
راح يجيب لي مصاري مثلا
جاوبوا بسؤال رائع قال له وما فائده الطفل
الطفل هذا الطفل ما فائدته
السؤال لكم شو فائده الطفل اذا بنفس
المبدا الطفل هو كائن صغير
خليط
بحس بخرب هذا لازم
على هذا الاساس لكن لا هذا الطفل لازم
يكبر لازم نعتني فيه ليطلع منه شيء
هالاستمتاع لا يكون فيه فائده مباشره
وانما فائدتها استراتيجيه يا جماعه نصيحه
لا تدرسوا الا شيء انتم تستمتعوا فيه اوكي
لازم يكون هو موافق لظروف وموافق للقدرات
والى اخره بس لازم تكون مستمتع فيه اذا مش
مستمتع فيه راح تكره حياتك ليش لانه انت
مستمتع فيه وحتى لو مش شاطر فيه على فكره
حتى لو مش شاطر فيه اللي بصير وقت انت
مستمتع فيه فشلت فيه تاخد نفس بترجع بتعيد
تاخد نفس بترجع بتيت فشلت فيه تاخد نفس
بترجع ليش لانه بتحبه لانه مبسوط فيه لانه
مستمتع فيه هذا الذي يولد الابداع
في الدراسه فالاختصاص فالشغله الثالثه
المهمه انه متعه الاستمتاع بالشيء في
الدراسه غير مستحيل يولد ابداع هو بنزين
الاساسي للابداع الشغله الاخيره
طبعا على فكره عدم وجود هذه النقطه بخلي
الناس تفهم الاختصاص اللي هو بده اياه
اللي هو شغال فيه غلط
مش فهمان هو شو بده راح لكم شغله مثل شو
مثل فيزياء الفيزياء هي ماده غش مش معروفه
في المجتمع بشكل عام يعني في مره انا عم
بمشي كان في جدي الله يعطيه الصحه بمشي في
البيت شوي شوي مشان ما يفيق فشافني
راحت لعنده اللي مو انت تبع الفيزياء
قلت له اللي صلح لي هالتلفزيون
فهو مش ذنبه
قلت له جدو يعني هذه علم يدرس في في
الظواهر الطبيعيه المهم قلعني يعني ما في
شي
الكلام هذا شيء طبيعي ليش
لانه بيعمل كره او عدم محبه الشيء ما في
اي حدا مستعد يسمعك فيه حتى انا لا احبه
لا لا تحكيلي وبالتالي لا ينتشر في
المجتمع اصلا وهذه نقطه اساسيه في تطور
المجتمعات اوف اهدا شوي نحن هلا بنحكي على
تطور مجتمعات
هو فيلسوف علمي بفلسفه العلم
قال من اساسيات تطور المنهجيه العلميه
الساين من اساسيات اول شيء شو خطواتها
الفرضيه وضع فرضيه بعدين التجربه بعدين
النتائج ومن ثم التطبيق
اما الاساسيات وضع الفرضيه الخيال
لانه انا بدي لقيت ظاهره لازم اشوف احاول
الاقي تفسير اذا ما عندي قوه خيال ما راح
يمشي الحال
ما راح يمشي الحال ما راح اعرف شو بدي
اتخيل والخيال بالضروره بالضروره
اصطحبه متعه لازم اكون مستمتع فيه غير هيك
انا مالي غير انه
لا لا خلاص بلا وبمشي اذا انا ماني مستمتع
في مشي الحال مشان هيك بتلاقي مثلا واحد
مثل اينشتاين
شو هالخيال اللي عندك اللي دمج الزمان مع
المكان وطالع نظريه جديده عمل قفزه وهو من
اساسيات التكنولوجيا الموجوده الان بين
ايدين على فكره
يلي بدي اقوله الا العلماء هكذا يفكرون
الشغله الاساسيه من الشغلات الاساسيه اللي
فيها هي متعه الاكتشاف المحافظه على هذه
المتعه هذه المتعه في اربعه شغلات اول
وحده هي فطره
بدكن اولادكم يطلعوا علماء
جواب طبعا ايه دعوهم على فطرتهم وقت هو
بده يعمل شغله بخرب شغلي
خليه يخربها هذه تجربه فيزيائيه طبعا انا
لا احرض على الخراب في البيت ولكن عطوه
مجال انه هو بتنكسر البيضه من ايده يعرف
انه تنكسر والالم لا ينكسر مثلا القلم لا
ينكسر اساله ليش خليه يفكر لا تعطي جواب
خليه يسال
بل ممكن تتجاوب عليه اكثر اللي هو بتعرف
هذا الشيء الاصفر الموجود اللي هلا طلع
هذا ممكن يطلع كتكوت صوص شو كيف روح فتحت
له باب اساسي من علم البيولوجيا هكذا
يصنعون العلماء هاي شغله اتركوهن على
فطرتهم ثاني شغله هي
وسيله فتاكه للتعلم اي معلم حابب يكون شخص
معلم قوي خلي طلابه يستمتعوا ولو دقيقه في
الجلسه ودقيقه واحده راح تشوفوا الاثر انا
وراهن الشغله الثالثه هي وسيله لتقويه
تخصصك مو اي شخص بيتخرج بكون شخص متخصص
الشخص المستمتع بتخصصه يكون شخص فعلا مبدع
شغل الرابعه هي انه هي ليست للمتعه فقط
بل هي لبناء المنظومه العلميه موضوع كبير
مش صغير بكلمات اخرى وختاما متعه اكتشاف
الاشياء تبدا بفتره طفوليه وتنتهي بنهضه
علميه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]